pr toute manière j'ai pu essayer les
juifs comme dans les volailles ses
conseillers dégueulasse épidémie
à la clé
mais orléans 150 mille habitants une
ville française classique et tranquille
sans histoire sans scandale
sans aventure et pourtant dans la
deuxième quinzaine du mois de mai 1969
un bruit commence à circuler trois femme
ligotée et drogué auraient été
découvertes dans la cave d'un magasin de
confection d'autres femmes auraient été
endormi en se piquant avec des aiguilles
cachés dans des talons chaussures la
rumeur affirme c'est grave il y à
orléans un réseau de traite des blanches
ce genre d'histoires circulait depuis
quelques années dans plusieurs villes de
france mais à orléans la ville entière
s'émeut le bruit s'amplifie plusieurs
femmes dit on aurait déjà disparu de
plusieurs magasins transporté par de
mystérieux souterrain jusqu'à la loire
où attend un sous marin les commerçants
trafic candidat lors la rumeur sont tous
des juifs et d'ailleurs tous les juifs
de la ville sont dans le coup l' affaire
devient une véritable campagne
antisémite la foule sa troupe devant les
magasins attaques et menaces insultes
la police est formel il n'y a pas eu de
disparition tout cela est absurde
la presse locale enquête et conclu tous
life
aujourd'hui pour les autorités que nous
avons vu l' affaire est classée deux
mois après nous avons voulu savoir ce
qui avait bien pu arriver aux paisibles
habitants d'orléans
alors vous madame vous entendez parler
de cette affaire
de quelle façon et bien j'étais à mon
bureau le lundi après midi et je suis
rentré en noir travail est une de mes
collègues d'une jeune femme d'une
vingtaine d'années ils me recevoir une
robe qui venait d'acheter
je t'en ai fait des compliments l'aider
tout contente il me dit vous avez je
suis pas près de retourner en acheter
d'autres
aidez vous ne connaissez pas l'histoire
de la traite des marches la traite des
blanches j'étais complètement éberlué
j'avais pas entendu parler de ces choses
j'ai très dérangeant mais qu'elle traite
des blanches ou même 10 dans les
magasins vous ne savez pas ça seedorf et
que ça soit un forfait
et puis au petit bénéfice bénéfices et
andy à d'autres magasins chéché lâché
félix le marchand de chaussures on a
trouvé des femmes endormies ange dit
qu'est ce que c'est cette histoire
d'orphée moi je connais très bien les
personnes qui tiennent au fait monsieur
reach et madame nietzsche sont mes amis
et ces histoires là ne tiennent pas
debout parce qu'ils sont incapables de
faire une malhonnêteté
andy va pourtant vous savez ça se passe
dans beaucoup de magasins
c'est sûr vous connaissez les normes ces
personnes du nom je connais pas leurs
noms mais ce que je sais ce sont des
magasins juifs
je voulais vous servir parce que les
noms de magath à goma est cité je savais
qu'ils étaient venus part d israël vie
et toute cette histoire c'est une cabale
anti sémite henry liste de propriétaire
d'un magasin de confection a été le
premier attaque
monsieur liste que s'est il passé
exactement
il ne s'est rien passé enfin le 23 mai
un avis vient me voir en me disant ma
fille a pris au lycée que il se passe de
drôles de choses chez toi qu'est-ce qui
se passe on a tu enlèves des femmes
tuent les droits gays est une et expédie
vers certains pays d'amérique du sud et
darracq sur le sur le moment cette
affaire m'a paru absolument ahurissante
j'en ai rigolé c'était la veille de la
pentecôte je suis parti pendant deux
jours le val cinq coups de théâtre je
reviens au magasin l'histoire avait fait
gonfler des mesures et nous nous
trouvions devant une véritable cabale
ce n'était plus une femme si on était
trois plus elle lui 15 puis 38
plusieurs magasins commençaient à être
cité et puis le 26 27 tous les magasins
juifs de la ville étaient pratiquement
dans le rang devant cet état de choses
nous seulement et unis nous sommes unis
nous avons décidé de porter plainte
le samedi 30 mai
devant notre magasin la foulée ça
trouble et se passe-t-il mais les gens
n'arrêtaient n'arrête pas de passer en
famille des dizaines et dizaines de
personnes
là-bas en passe partout nous montre du
doigt nous insulte
il
ils nous envoient des grossièretés ce
mac user de tous les maux mais s'il y
avait vraiment beaucoup de monde
ah oui énormément énormément de monde
plusieurs centaines certainement et et
les gens de demander que la provocation
certaines personnes et vous vous n'avez
pas bougé nous sommes ici vous aviez
bouger que se serait-il passé
je ne sais pas mais je crois que ça
aurait fait devenir les grands et
pourquoi il ya utile du monde c'était
jour de marché
oui et les environs étaient descendus en
thaïlande nous sommes aperçus que même à
100 kilomètres à la ronde les gens
étaient au courant de l'histoire
est ce que vous avez reçu des menaces
directes maintenant mais enfin certains
jeunes en passant devant le magasin on
dit donnez nous une mitraillette on va
rentrer dans ce magasin était tout le
monde vous avez reçu des coups de
téléphone des coups de téléphone
anonymes douzaine peut-être plusieurs
voix ou une seule voix deux voix une
voix masculine une voix féminine journée
mais on vous disait quoi on préparait
préparer préparer un convoi nous
arrivons presque pour une robe on gagne
à voyager et certaines fois on
décrochait sa mort n'est pas est-ce que
vous avez reçu des lettres
non aucune est ce qu'il ya eu des tracts
deviendrait presque des inscriptions sur
les murs aucune inscription est à dire
c'était uniquement par voie orale est ce
que cette affaire vous a causé des
préjudices préjudice économique oui quel
pendant quelques jours nous avons eu la
désertion du magasin depuis 02 normal
morale c'est énorme c'est à dire
aujourd'hui en fous pareils parce que et
basse faut-il se considérer comme à
l'heure actuelle comme citoyens à part
entière devant la loi ou simplement
serons-nous toujours des juifs avant
tours vous êtes professeur dans un lycée
quelle était l'attitude d'une part des
élèves et celle des professeurs de
vocaux l'allier et bien je me suis
aperçu que
après avoir été mise aux grandes
affaires mois que les élèves étaient
bien été au courant de cette affaire et
l'avait été bien avant moi et que j'en
parlais on en parlait dans les classes
les filles surtout en parler elle était
très excitée ça leur plaisait beaucoup
je ne parlait que de ça c'est à dire sur
leur pelouse en quel sens ça les excite
est c'est une histoire qui les killers
qui les amuse et enfin qu à laquelle
elle croyait fermement les professeurs
comment tu réagis bien moi le lundi j'ai
voulu les mettre au courant et je me
suis aperçue qu'elle était au courant
depuis huit jours et qu'elle ne m'en
avait pas parlé
elle parlait derrière mon dos et ne
voulant pas en parler parce que il
s'agissait de membres de ma famille et
puis je suis juive est alors quand j'ai
mis au courant une professeur el mahdi a
en effet ce jeu savez on en parlait mais
je ne savais pas m'a dit je savais pas
que c'était vraiment antisémite cette
histoire et puis je les revues une heure
après elle m'a dit mais après tout
pourquoi vous prendrai peut-être que la
police et est acheté une camarade de
classe m'avertit en me disant tu sais
voilà ce qui se passe à orléans des
magasins sont incriminés dans la traite
des blanches et enfin juste averti et en
ce moment là plusieurs camarades sont
approchés elle nous a avertis à nous a
dit surtout je vous dis ça uniquement
pour que vous n'alliez pas tout seul il
faut absolument pas s'allier avec des
parents accompagnés enfin deux quidams
et elle c'est cette rumeur c'était
par sa belle-soeur c'était arrivé face
aux stars iv à la femme dynamique sa
belle soeur mais se déroulait sous forme
de petites conversations particulière de
secret qui se serait glissée dans chaque
oreille qui aurait été répétée par tout
le monde malgré tout c'était des petits
clans qui se formait de 2 ou 3 et qui
sera content et ça alors le bruit s'est
répandu de cette façon à travers tout le
lycée il ya combien d'élèves dans votre
lit ses amis et tout le monde en a parlé
la rumeur disait aussi attention aux
cabines d'essayage c'est ce qui a frappé
de guerre morin sociologue qui enquêtait
orléans sur la faire il faut se rendre
compte que le salon d'essayage surtout
dans une eau pour des jeunes filles qui
dansent vont avoir leur premier
événement de femmes et surtout dans
l'est dans les villes qui commence à se
moderniser depuis ces dernières années
c'est un endroit un peu fabuleuse c'est
un endroit on se met nue ou se dévêt on
se regarde dans une glace mais on est
enfermé comme un comme dans un w c mais
pas vraiment n'y a qu'un rideau qui
sépare il ya beaucoup de fantasmes
érotiques n'est ce pas qui peuvent
naître des séances d'essayage donc ça
fait quelque chose d'assez troublant ce
qui à mon avis explique que cette rumeur
de traite des blanches salon d'essayage
epicure courait depuis des années
disons depuis des années depuis sept ou
huit ans au moins dans plusieurs villes
dans paris alors la chose qui est
extraordinaire c'est que quand cette ce
récit le traite des blanches période en
noir et blanc n'y a pas de juifs
il semble que quand elle court dans une
très grande ville comme dans paris le
thème du jaune apparaît pas mais dès
qu'elle s'incarne dans une petite ville
tire dès qu'on dit ça se passe ici
eh bien il ya une sorte de force
irrésistible qui la fixe sur le
commerçant juif
le fantôme du juif qui dans le monde de
chrétien occidental est celui qui fixe
une angoisse qui prend en charge la
culpabilité est finalement qu on va
sacrifier comme bouc émissaire ce
fantôme du juif commencent à sortir des
profondeurs où on le croyait à jamais un
flux alors c'est ça à mon avis le
terrain favorable
de cette rumeur à ce moment là les gens
disent mais pourquoi est ce que la
police n'arrête pas ses commerçants
pourquoi est ce que la presse sauter
parce qu'elle est acheté par les juifs
elle presse et police c'est vous avez
une sorte de spasmes de délires
antisémites extrêmement passagers et
presque encore inconscient on va passer
du cas singulier c'est un commerçant
juif au cas à l'idée générale à ces
juifs quand même ils sont bien tous les
mêmes mais ce n'est pas ça l'important
ce stade là l'important c'est que pour
les parents et pour certains éducateurs
ils voilà l'illustration concrète du
danger que représente pour eux toute
cette nouvelle mode pour la jeunesse et
pour la jeunesse féminine la minute jus
saint germain des prés le yéyé paris
tout cela est symbolisée dans ces
nouveaux magasins modernes avec ce
nombre d'essayage et pour eux c'est
l'occasion de dire leur enfant effrayé
vous voyez mes enfants fait attention on
commence par la musique qu'on ne sait
pas où ça peut conduire
accusés d'être des trafiquants menacés
dans la rue chez eux tous les jours 100
ans
l'intoxication psychologique gagné
dangereusement toute la ville et les
environs
les commerçants attaque et décident de
se réunir ils veulent réagir avec les
organisations antiracistes le mrap et la
licra
ils tiennent des meetings la presse
locale les soutiens des envoyés spéciaux
arrive de bas il paraît que l'on a
beaucoup parlé dans la ville mais on
raconter quoi exactement quel était pour
acheter puis contre la jamaïque avait
dit qu'elle était séquestrée
finalement pris beaucoup de boulot de
magasin en magasin mais parie que tout
le monde en a parlé oui on disparaît
pour le jour des filles d'attendre les
premiers jours on en a parlé pendant la
rixe entre nous c'était la mas de rivals
à la blague et on a blagué si vous
voulez nous faire partir sur suse et là
pas question
en principe c'est quelque chose qu'ils y
sont relativement bref mais j'admets
était plein de petits feux un petit feu
mais ce que dernièrement des histoires
de ce genre à caractère raciste se sont
produites en lire il ya eu des affaires
raciste moment de la guerre d'algérie un
peu après lors d'une conférence de kateb
yacine ici alors surtout l'année
dernière il ya eu une affaire qui
n'était pas uniquement raciste c est l
attaque de la cité universitaire de
d'orléans la source ou alors là en
pleine nuit une centaine de gaillard
dont certains étaient armés sont venus
sortir les étudiants de leur chambre
tabassé et s'en prenant particulièrement
aux étudiants africains
alors là la sphère a fait beaucoup de
bruit à l'époque
maintenant la mli style vient
interrompre toute poursuite
mais enfin il faut noter qu orléans
était la seule ville de france où une
attaque de cette importance et ce style
a eu lieu est ce qu'on va faire une
corrélation entre les deux on est
évidemment tenté de faire une
corrélation si on croit à la thèse de la
fabrication dans la sphère des
commerçants dormir comme moi j'y crois
je fais évidemment une corrélation
[Musique]
tous les ans comme dans beaucoup de
villes de france
une braderie a lieu durant trois jours
dans les rues commerçantes d'orléans
c'est deux mois après laffaire elle a
laissé des traces n'ont cependant
islamique
quand même c'est une réaction parce que
vous étiez sur une bourgogne en
particulier est une rue très commerçante
s'est il ya d'autres rues qui sont
commerçante mais qui sont gênés par les
commerçants de la rue de bourgogne
alors comme ici c'est un milieu
israélite et bien le bouc émissaire de
la femme enlevée ça très bien servi tout
le monde dont les habitants disent à des
besoins et moi même on me l'a raconté à
moi j'ai dit à dos et on vous le
rappelle est cru au début moi
et tellement de brume du tout qu'ils
encourraient des patriotes de très
nombreux démentis dans la presse je
pense que le real est un peu raciste est
en moi ga siens une faute de gauche
alors un scandale une calomnie réaction
du dégoût ça m'a fait penser exactement
à ce que les allemands pu faire pendant
la guerre j'aimais ce qui me déçoit le
plus c'est que la 4 90% de la population
orléanaise aussi bien que les alentours
c'est à dire ferrol ouvroir l'ont cru et
ça c'est la pire des choses
et pourquoi ce mot n'ya cru quand une
chose va pas ce sont les juifs
demain ce sera les arabes après ce
seront les portugais comprenez il faut
qu'il y ait une brebis galeuses moi j'ai
été voir la police et le commissaire
principal que j'ai vu m'a dit pendant la
période dont on parle il n'y a même pas
une fugue ce qui avait pu fuir quelques
on aurait pu la créditer sur cette
affaire-là non pas question il n'a pas
même pas eu une femme qui a disparu à
orléans je te moques là la police a dit
c'est terminé c'est pas vrai c'est
entièrement faux n'en parlons plus est
terminée mais vous n'arrivez pas à
arrêter un bruit de ce bruit là dans un
an par encore je suis certain que dans
un an il ya des gens qui continueront à
dire que l'on sait magasin d'à et les
femmes qui partent orléans cas ce que
c'est c'est une ville très équilibré
une ville qui se permet d'avoir 26 ou 27
clocher mais en même temps 22 boîte de
nuit
c'est je crois la démonstration d'un
parfait équilibre humains sociales
géographiques et climatiques
il n'y a pas de tremblement de terre il
n'y a pas de typhon il se passe rien
parler un peu se passe rien on vit
heureux on est bien
[Musique]